so there's something
special about that one.
You can check these equations directly by looking at these vectors and considering what happens
for the standard basis states
swapping the two classical states for the first three Bell
states doesn't do anything we get the same state we started with.
In the fourth case however, the minus sign effectively
moves from one term to the other when we perform the swap of the classical states,
and that's equivalent to multiplying the vector by minus one.
So performing the swap operation somehow kicks out a minus sign
from this fourth Bell state.
We'll have more to say about
these equations later on, but now let's move on to
another type of operation, which is a controlled operation.
We're going to suppose that X is a Qubit and Y is any system you want.
If U as a unitary operation on Y, then a controlled U operation on XY is the operation that's
expressed right here.
First, using the direct notation and then using what's
called a block matrix you just imagined filling
in this bigger matrix
with the smaller ones where these zeros really represent matrices
filled with zeros.
So each of these four blocks represents a matrix having a number
of rows and columns that agrees with the number
of classical states of Y.
The idea of a controlled operation, which we already encountered
in the classical setting when we discussed a
controlled NOT operation,
is that if X is set to zero,
then nothing happens to Y.
But if X is set to one,
then U is applied to Y.
So X is called the control Qubit, and Y is called the target system, which in general doesn't
have to be a Qubit.
For a specific example,
which I just mentioned, we have a controlled NOT operation.
If the first qubit is set
to zero, nothing happens. And if the first qubit is set to one, then a NOT operation or equivalently,
a sigma X operation is
applied to the second Qubit.
And here is it's matrix representation.
We're talking about two Qubits here, so we could equally well
decide that the second Qubit is the control and the
first is the target.
To describe that operation, we just swap the ordering
in the tensor product, and the result is the matrix
that you see right here.
If instead of a controlled-NOT operation, we consider a controlled sigma
Z or controlled Z operation.
We obtain this matrix
representation right here. And for this one, it doesn't actually matter
which is the control and which is the target.
We get the same result either way.
We can go further and we can consider a controlled swap operation.
And here we're talking
about swapping two Qubits, so we end up with three Qubits when we include the controlled Qubit.
Each matrix representation
looks like this.
It's pretty special operation and it's known as a Fredkin operation, or more commonly a Fredkin gate.
When we think about it
as a gate in a circuit, we'll discuss circuits in the next lesson.
The last example is a controlled,
controlled-NOT operation, which again is an
operation on three Qubits.
And here's its matrix representation. This operation is much better
known as a Toffli operation or a Toffoli gate.
We'll discuss it further
and we'll see why both it and the Fredkin can operation are very important
operations in a later lesson.
And that is the end of the second lesson. In this lesson, we discussed how quantum information works for multiple systems.
I hope you'll join me for
the third lesson soon, which is on quantum circuits
protocols and games.
Bye until then.